also ich war wieder mal entsetzt ich
meine letzten zwei jahren öfter sind
setzt aber wenn ich dann wieder was
tagesaktuelles sehe lauterbach empfiehlt
die vierte impfung für alle weil in der
korona sommer welle 4 stelligen sie denn
zahl möglich sind ja also da sind wir
wieder bei dieser angst und panikmache
die wir in den letzten zwei jahren
wirklich zu genüge mitgekriegt haben ich
bin psychologe das heißt ich untersuche
in der wissenschaft die verbindung
zwischen psyche und immunsystem wir
brauchen unser immunsystem
wir brauchen es gestärkt so gut es geht
die sind gehabt situation wo
wir sind eine situation wo wir
eigentlich ruhe geben könnten was dieses
thema betrifft ja also omikron das ist
einfach ein witz mittlerweile ja also
dass wir die die intensivstationen sind
leer das ist eine um vielfach geringer
wie eine leichte grippe also das heißt
wir haben hier überhaupt kein problem
und trotzdem wird wieder angst und panik
gemacht es wird von instanzen geredet
ohne es zu differenzieren das heißt es
wird nicht
eine infektions incidents offensichtlich
von der redet weil die krankheit sind
instanz muss sein ok satellit wohl auch
nicht also um was geht es hier es geht
hier nichts anderes als panikmache und
dann geht es darum ein impfstoff wieder
unter die leute zu kriegen ganz
offensichtlich weil ja alle sich impfen
lassen müssen beim solar harmlosen
geschichte die wir da draußen haben also
wo ich mir etwas darf denn damals
passiert denn hier und na ja wir haben
jetzt gerade die die die akzeptanz ganz
offensichtlich auch der impfung unter
fünfjährigen also wirklich bei
kleinkindern also das ist ein drama das
ist ein verbrechen für mich ja kinder in
diesem alter die von q wie schon zu
beginn mit
nebenwirkungen ich war noch massiv
forums nebenwirkungen ganz
offensichtlich da sind wenn sie nicht
berichtet also das heißt wir haben ein
desaster daraus
wenn man den spiegel aber würde den
spiegel -bericht ganz in ruhe mal
durchgeht und ich setze mich sehr mit
texten auseinander dann muss man sagen
ist das sehr schaumgebremst da ist die
handbremse drin wieder geredet wird über
die ems probleme und ich würde eher
sagen dem bleibt gar nichts anderes mehr
übrig als nur zu reden und zu versuchen
das ganze in ihre ecke zu bringen
nämlich so schlimm ist es nicht
lange damit befasst ich bin auch
definitiv skeptisch gegenüber auch
gerade jetzt als reaktion auf meinen
euro psycho runden psychomotorische
erkrankungen beziehungsweise
neuropsychiatrische kann man das
tourette-syndrom sich aber
offensichtlich und da habe ich mir viele
gedanken binder auch tatsächlich
skeptisch weil ich eben auch in der
vergangenheit auf im bund so stark
reagiert habe also schon an schon von
grund auf und habe der frau belastet
genau wie nach vorbelastet auch viel
außen hat auch ein ehrenvolles kreis
eben auch von menschen gehört die ihm
auch probleme waren die ihnen da auch
probleme gekriegt haben sei es kleinere
geschichten aber bis hin zu größeren
sachen und da bin ich muss ich ehrlich
sagen auch kritisch ja ich definitiv
sagen
ja also ich muss ihnen jetzt mal wieder
sprechen ja schon ein bisschen musik
hier reinbringen also sie haben gerade
gesagt es gebe jetzt eine pflicht sich
irgendwie impfen zu lassen das haben wir
natürlich in deutschland nicht darüber
wurde er diskutiert jeder kann sich
impfen lassen bis die indirekten zweig
naja ich musste nicht die orte aufsuchen
insofern man wurde ausgeschlossen aus
der selbst ja aber da war die situation
noch eine andere jetzt würde ich sagen
es muss man neu bewerten ob zweig
wirklich erforderlich ist aber die
impfung als solche dass die natürlich
auch dafür gesorgt hat dass
krankheitsverläufe will woher wissen sie
dass ich bin jetzt kein experte wie sie
aber als politikerin ist es schon meine
aufgabe mich auch zu informieren und
auch sachlich zu informieren und das was
ich verstanden habe ist dass eine
impfung sehr wohl schützt zumindest zu
einem milderen verlauf führt und ich
muss auch als politikerin ihn sagen
gesamtgesellschaftlich ist es ein segen
dass wir den impfstoff haben das auch
innovation so schnell auch in der
forschung voran ging denn wenn wir einen
stärkeren panini verlauf gehabt hätten
dann wäre das problematisch für die
intensivstationen gewesen und für unsere
kritische infrastruktur wenn ihr in
berlin die halbe polizei oder feuerwehr
flach liegt oder sehr schlag erkrankt
ist haben wir hier eben auch ein
gesamtgesellschaftliches problem und ich
bin nicht für einen impfzwang aber ich
kann jedem raten der soll nicht getan
hat sich impfen zu lassen um sich selber
zu schützen es sei denn man hat
besondere versierte impfung machen so
weit dass im frühling ist auch für meine
altersgruppe ja und ich habe auch meine
kinder impfen lassen aber da ist die
frage dann wäre empfiehlt das eigentlich
ich habe jetzt den herrn lauterbach
gehört als gesundheitsminister dir das
quasi empfiehlt das finde ich schon ein
einer stau ein erstaunliches vorgehen er
hat mir medizin studiert ja habe ich
auch mal das haben viele leute mal
aber der punkt ist doch tatsächlich ob
er nun medizin steht oder nicht er ist
gesundheitsminister und als
gesundheitsminister macht er keine
empfehlung oder hat er keine empfehlung
und dafür zu geben dafür gibt es die
stiko die ständige impfkommission und da
kann man nun darüber geteilter meinung
sein aber die stieg und zum beispiel
würde diese führte impfung kenne es
ihren gesundheitszustand nicht aber ich
vermute mal dass sie da jetzt gar nicht
in frage kam
stieg um vielleicht noch eines tages das
mal verändert aber da würde ich doch
sagen dann lassen wir das lieber den
gremien übrig die dafür eingesetzt zu
den nebenwirkungen es natürlich wenn
meine frage als bürgerin wird hier
übertrieben auf der seite recht also ich
bin nicht mit allen punkten einig aber
mit vielen natürlich schon was was sind
punkt angeht der ausgrenzung derer die
da auch mal kritische anmerkung haben
vor allen dingen dieses typisch aber
nicht nur deutsches phänomen alle gleich
in dieselbe schublade zu stecken es gibt
nur zwei die platte ihren auf die
empfohlen dass man dass man hier über
und seit zwei jahren nicht wirklich
offen diskutieren kann ich meine damit
offen das nicht gleich wie auf twitter
niveau sofort gegeneinander aufrechnen
das ist das macht keinen spaß also wenn
man sich wissenschaftlich
auseinandersetzen kann finde ich das
völlig in ordnung aber das ist alles so
unsachlich geworden von von vielen
seiten und das finde ich dass ich nicht
in ordnung dass der spiegel dass
gebracht hat ja völlig klar ich denke
aber auch er konnte gar nicht mehr
anders das hätten die vor anderthalb
jahren nicht gemacht wird könnte man
sagen fan und habe es nicht gewusst aber
etwas musste man schon häufig werden in
der sendung auch früh über impfschäden
gesprochen und auch nebenwirkungen und
wir haben auch über corona also ich bin
halt immer etwas skeptisch aber ich bin
auch mit diesem medienhaus gesegnet muss
man sagen habe so harte corona meinungen
vertreten und deswegen immer wenn gesagt
wird man durfte es nicht vertreten er
rede ich vielleicht auch als
journalistin geschützt und dann noch als
journalistin bei axel springer das muss
ich wirklich sagen ich hab ich immer das
gefühl vielleicht wollten viele
vielleicht hatten viele auch nicht diese
meinung also es gab vielleicht auch in
anderen häusern journalisten die anders
gedacht haben aber ohne dass die
meinungsfreiheit einschränken wollten
ich glaube ich habe es nicht zugleich
ständig habe ich verstehe ich etwas
hinein also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
so wie sie es kalt mobilität haben da
höre ich die angst und die panik durch
für etwas was im prinzip längst belegt
ist nicht so schlimm ist normal wir
haben eine case für telegate wir haben
eine fall sterblichkeit die liegt bei
0,7 prozent eine infektion sterblichkeit
bei 0,12 prozent juni ist so sehr
renommierter epidemiologe als amerika
hier sind die zahlen alle ganz klar wir
wissen ganz genau wen es trifft es
trifft sehr alte und ge sehr kranke
menschen mit ganz bestimmten
krankheitskeimen das ist das was das
problem ist halo ja und wir stellten
dass wir die gesamte gesellschaft wir
machen hier einen lock down wir wir
machen die schulen zu wir riskieren
menschen leben in einem ausmaß das ist
breit über das was sagt das aus zwei
jeweils machen würde und für mich ist
für mich ist das ein für mich ist es ein
1 1 ein sinnbild cupid 19 für eine
missratene medizin die den menschen jede
maschine behandelt die die differenz
zwischen körper seele und geist macht ja
die haben keine zusammenhang die haben
nie daran gedacht wäre der mensch
wirklich ist sondern sie sind im prinzip
los geschossen und haben das virus in
den blickpunkt genommen und den menschen
dabei vergessen und das ist nicht die
medizin für die ich studiert habe und
meine demokratischen eid geleistet hat
nebenbei ich will den menschen ganz
behandeln und und das ist nicht passiert
und wir werden
katastrophen in zukunft haben wenn es um
unser unsere gesundheit der bevölkerung
geht für zwei jahre wo wir letzten wenn
es längst ein großteil der bevölkerung
hätten in eine so genannte
herdenimmunität bringen können indem wir
sie sich infizieren lassen weil es eben
nicht
ich hatte natürlich hatte ich hab's auch
heftig also ich wäre es gar nicht sagen
dass ich da locker durch gegangen bin er
weiß halt macht an meiner meinung ändert
nichts an meiner meinung geändert ich
würde ganz gerne mal einen run mir ganz
wichtig sie haben gerade gesagt ist da
hier keine
offene debatte möglich sie haben gerade
angesprochen ob hier irgendwo
meinungsfreiheit beschränkt wird das ist
doch in deutschland überhaupt nicht der
fall es kann jeder die meinung sagen ihr
habt den straßen in berlin große corona
leugner demos von menschen die einfach
sagen
ja ich wollte mich auf den punkt machen
da waren ganz verschiedene menschen auch
mit abos politisch sehr heterogen
meinung und es war gott sei dank die
pflicht auch hier von polizei und stadt
auch meinung dass die gesellschaft auch
meinung trägt und auch versammlungen
schützt und diesem warmen die haben
diese versammlung demonstration möglich
gemacht und wir sind ja gott sei dank in
einem demokratischen system wo durchaus
auch sehr unterschiedliche meinungen im
deutschen bundestag diskutiert aber holt
sich eine einschränkung schnell da
müssen sie mir ist ja nicht so dass die
meinungen irgendwie leider erlaubt aber
eine zahl müssen sie bleibe ihnen zu ja
ein doktor specht zu ja wir müssen
wieder zu einem sachlicheren niveau kopf
aber es ist nicht richtig dass man hier
in deutschland seiner meinung nicht eine
zwischenfrage müssen sie mir erlauben
sie haben gerade selber gesagt sie habe
nicht gesagt dass haben demonstrationen
dagegen steige von sondern sie haben
gesagt oder sonst ration sogleich wieder
beleben das ist halt wertung ja darf ich
aus ihre werte wie empfinden sie dass
die menschen die gegen die maßnahmen
waren schon wenn sie nicht journalisten
waren journalisten wie ich waren
geschützt ich würde auch sagen es gibt
die meinungsfreiheit definitiv sonntag
aber meine hosen dann muss sie wirklich
gucken gehen dass aber alle geschützt
und ich darf meine meinung sagen ja ich
bin juristin natürlich also wie gesagt
und sie nur ich bin normal und alle
anderen sind verrückt aber ich geb dir
gefallen ist das geschehe und glauben so
lange war bei den menschen immer noch da
das die gerne gesagt haben ich habe mich
gegen die impfung entschieden ich bin
nicht für alle maßnahmen also ich habe
viele diskussionen geführt wird heute
wieder mit menschen sagen ich hab mich
nicht geimpft weil ausdehnen und den
gründen andere haben mir gesagt ich hab
nicht geimpft ich sagte meiner meinung
dazu und ich habe ich muss wirklich auch
sagen hier aus demokratischen gründen
kann ich das nicht so stehen lassen wenn
sie sagen man darf hier in deutschland
seine meinung nicht aus dass das wetter
ist ihr bestes beispiel dafür sehr
aufgeregt manchmal auch zu aufgeregt ich
würde es mir wirklich sachlich auf unten
noch mit mehr experten wissen ich habe
keinen paten wissen aber dass hier die
meinungsfreiheit nicht existiert oder
nur auf dem papier das ist so überhaupt
glaube sie haben auch den kontakt zu
menschen verloren weil war dass man sie
da gerade sagen ich kann ihnen sagen den
gesundheitssystemen in den
krankenhäusern in situationen wo ich mit
menschen kontakt habe die sind
verzweifelt die können überhaupt nicht
ihre meinung sagen weil du verlieren sie
ihren job wir haben sie selber schon
probleme weil sie sind ja sehr kritisch
an ihrer uni oder ruanda natürlich hatte
ich probleme ich hab ne ich habe schon
mehrere disziplinarverfahren durch die
ärztekammer bekommen für aussagen die
wissenschaftlich sind ja das wurde auch
wieder zurückgezogen na ja weil es jetzt
gerade nicht schick ist ja ein arzt zu
verknappen weil es so langsam ein
bisschen aber ich hatte durchaus 9000
euro strafe bedingt bekommen ich meine
entschuldigung wo sind wir denn hier
dass sowas passiert das ärzten die
approbation entzogen wird das ihnen
gedroht wird die opposition zu entziehen
das ist das sind lebens existenzen wir
reden hier nicht von kleinen
kavaliersdelikte nja und dafür ist die
politik verantwortlich und das habe ich
zwei jahre überhaupt nicht gesehen dass
ich hier eigentlich jetzt wird von den
menschen weder von der medizin noch von
der politik und noch von den medien
neben
drei die zusammen einiges angerichtet
netz vor allem sehr haube und gerade
jetzt dass sie auch ansprechende dieser
meinungsfreiheit die natürlich im
freundeskreis oder auch im externen
chrysler mit leuten einem tisch saß hat
man sehr oft gemerkt dass auch
unterschiedliche meinungen gelten
gelassen wurde also ich habe das oft
habe ich unterhalt mit leuten die total
zum beispiel das thema in poing barren
anderen totaler liegen und deshalb
funktioniert aber im netz hat es in kein
einziges mal funktioniert das heißt
sobald irgendwas geschrieben und leute
waren so über emotional zum teil dass
man also dass kommentare gemeldet wurden
und so geschichten dass man also
wirklich gleich
abgestempelt wurde und das ist mir
einfach gerade auf den sozialen
netzwerken vielmehr aufgefallen als es
mehr so im gespräch mit menschen
aufgefallen ist also das ist vielleicht
was was man da noch mit einer infusion
war doch sehr lebhaft und auch
heterogene ich bin ja eine politikerin
hier in berlin bildungspolitikerin und
es gab glaube ich kein thema was so
umstritten war allein in einem gruppe
der eltern
in den schulen schließen die
schulschließung muss man wirklich sagen
auch blickend ich beschäftige mich sehr
auch mit dem thema häusliche gewalt und
psychische schäden bei kindern vor allem
hat natürlich und da kommen wir dann zu
den punkten was ist wirklich notwendig
was nicht hat große schäden verursacht
für die kinder und das können und dürfen
wir uns auch so nicht mehr erlauben ziel
muss es sein wenn wir jetzt mal gucken
was steht an das für den herbst oder für
das was kommt
oberstes ziel ist dass die kinder in
schulen und kitas gehen können und dass
die jungen leute auch möglichst im
präsenz in die unis gehen können sie
werden das fachlich noch besser
beurteilen können aber die schäden die
da auch entstanden sind auch psychischer
art
dass das können wir als erwachsene
unseren jungen leuten nicht zumuten